I want to start today with something I've
mentioned before, but I think it's really
time to have a more detailed conversation
about and this is what I'm calling
and some others are calling coronavirus vaccine
alarmism, which really has to stop now. I want
to be really clear. Coronavirus vaccine alarmism.
I'm not talking about anti vaccine people here.
I'm not talking about people who say the
vaccine is unsafe or that it's microchips
or that Bill Gates has some nefarious role to play
or that it's a population control device or that
it modifies your DNA. That's a.. That's what
I'm talking about. Here is what I guess makes
sense to call vaccine alarmism, which is people
who are fine with vaccines as far as we know.
But the sort of disproportionate focus on
the vaccines aren't 100 percent effective.
We don't know if anything can change when you
were vaccinated and other types of talking points
that are inadvertently maybe reducing interest in
the vaccine and by so doing are actually going to
have the effect of extending the pandemic. The New
York Times had a great article about this called
Vaccine Alarmism by David Leonhardt looking at
the costs of vaccine alarmism. And in the article,
David points out that there are hot takes and
opinion pieces being widely published right
now that start with something like, listen, the
coronavirus vaccine is not 100 percent effective.
If you are vaccinated, you might still be
able to transmit the disease to other people.
The variants might make the vaccines
irrelevant, and no one's behavior can change,
even when vaccinated for a really long time
without making it clear what needs to change for
people's behavior to be able to change. And when
you kind of take it all together, it starts to
sound like, well, the pandemic will never end and
the vaccine changes nothing for me. So why even go
through the hassle of looking for an appointment
and getting a vaccine, especially if it's not
100 percent effective and you can still transmit
the disease and you can't change your behavior
in any way for the foreseeable future? Now, if
you break down, it actually functions much like a
conspiracy theory. You hear it all together and
it's like, wow, yeah. That that that's a lot.
But if you break down each piece into its
component parts, you find that while there is
some truth to each individual, claim there is
so much missing context and you end up with a
completely distorted view about vaccines, let's
actually do it and break it down. For example,
the vaccine is not 100 percent effective. OK,
yeah, that's true. But with the Fizer and Moderna
vaccines at 92 to 95 percent effective, these are
some of the most effective vaccines in the history
of vaccination. And importantly, not only are they
92 to 95 percent effective, they are almost one
hundred percent effective at preventing serious
covid. And so when you start hearing, well,
it's not 100 percent effective. And I don't know,
that is extraordinarily misleading. And it is a
huge, huge, huge additional amount of information
you need beyond they're not 100 percent effective,
not one percent effective, but there are of
the most effective vaccines we've ever had,
and they are almost 100 percent effective at
preventing severe covid, which is what's killing
people. OK, next, it is true that vaccinated
people may still be contagious. What that means is
that the phase three trials on which the vaccines
were approved didn't look at the effect of the
vaccines on transmissibility. However, early data
from Israel suggests that what was expected is
what is happening, which is that these vaccines,
Fizer and Moderna, do reduce transmission. Again,
it's not been studied and reported in a peer
reviewed study and we want to be careful.
But the early information from Israel corroborates
what was expected, which is that we expected the
vaccines would cut. Transmission hasn't been
studied. In the way that it needs to be studied,
so then we get to even if you get a vaccine,
you can't change your behavior for a really,
really long time. OK, let's dig into that in
more detail. It is true that just getting a shot
doesn't mean that right away you should be doing
anything differently, particularly if nobody else
in your circles is vaccinated. But once you are
fully vaccinated, meaning your seven days passed,
your second dose, the risk from being
with other fully vaccinated people,
especially if they work from home, is very, very
low. And again, with everyone being vaccinated,
you are reducing the risk below that of the
flu because the vaccines are so effective at
preventing severe covid. So does it make the risks
zero? No, it doesn't. But nothing has zero risk
during flu season, particularly with flu
vaccines only 20 to 50 percent effective.
We are accepting a certain level of risk
when we're around people during that time.
Increasingly, virologists and immunologists and
others are understanding that the vaccine is
being undersold. Doctor Music, who's a virologist,
said in The New York Times piece. Our discussion
about vaccines has been poor, really poor. As
scientists, we need to be more careful what we say
and how it would be understood by the public. And
the focus has been uncertainty, possible bad news,
and it's making people not want the vaccine.
The vaccine isn't a catch all. Do whatever the
hell you want, sort of get out of jail free card.
The policies and grocery stores will be for masks
for some time to come. Also at doctors offices and
other lots of other places, no doubt. But let's be
more realistic. A small group of fully vaccinated
people who work from home can responsibly choose
to accept the small risk of being together. And
part of the problem and part of the reason why we
need all of the fear, uncertainty and doubt to be
the top line is that so many people either don't
understand a lot of this stuff or can't use sound
judgment. So everybody has to be extra careful.
But the reality is the more people that get the
vaccine more quickly, the sooner normality or
something like it can return. So we have to stop
underselling the vaccine. We have to make clear
that a lot of these catchall umbrella statements
are making people disinterested in the vaccine,
and that's only going to prolong
the pandemic. No one is advocating
irresponsible behavior. Some of these headlines
that are floating around are a disaster and they
are making it so that so many people don't want
the vaccine. I'll have an example of this later
today for you in the voicemail segment. For the
time being, let's move on to a few other things.